les gens ne font pas ce truc parce
qu'ils recherchent le grand amour il
fallait rencontrer quelqu'un est donné à
leur dire minable un tout petit brin de
folie
c'est comme aller dans un bar le
vendredi soir mais sans tout ce qui fait
chier dans un bar le vendredi soir non
je suis capable de deviner ce que les
gens voient film faut juste un mois -
silence ce que je bois votre katana et
les canons du clae sa gauche à droite il
s'est passé poivre cette dernière la
dernière tu crois que tu as vraiment
tout compris c'est ça je vois les choses
comme ça ouais quoi qu'est ce que tu dit
'cela dit cgtg qu'on s'entendrait telle
question je suis vierge
je crois que du poisson qui fait qu'on
allait signer les plus compatibles
[Musique]
raté la réunion d'hier portable a pas
sonné s'est passé fait que j'ai
accidentellement être pourquoi tu as
fais ça tu sais à quel point c'est
important aujourd'hui
robbie a fait la présentation c'est lui
qui récupère le client faut vraiment
être taré pour éteindre le réveil de
quelqu'un non j'ai pas répondu harris
cette amère elle dit que c'est urgent
bonsoir
t'as pas répondu à mes texan
nous avons une autorisation pour
fouiller votre domicile oui votre
ordinateur possession de pornographie
infantile
je sais que c'était toi quel effet ça
fait harry
ça suffit comme ça
vous risquez une peine de prison
conséquentes
ma vie est foutue tu voulais juste
donner à ta vie minable petit grain de
folie c'est bien ça
[Applaudissements]
ya ka k